the mid to late 1970s an economist by
the name of Milton Friedman offered an
entirely new definition of the purpose
of business he said the purpose of
business is to maximize profit within
the bounds of the law
that's a very low standard like what
about ethics right
um but this new definition of business
which was simply to maximize profit
believe it or not that wasn't the
definition of the responsibility of the
business prior right it was more Adam
Smith which is to produce great product
and great product is how we you know
take care of the consumer and that's
what makes us Thrive and all of that
stuff
and it shifted the the focus of business
inwards and a lot of Executives embraced
it
and you started to see that miltonian
embracement of uh really start to gain
momentum in the 80s and was full-fledged
in the 90s and 2000s so it has nothing
to do with Republican or Democrat we saw
it Fly and we saw policy change to
embrace that definition so for example
there was no such thing as using mass
layoffs on a regular basis to manage the
numbers there was no such thing as mass
labs to balance the books prior to the
early 1980s it did not exist
it was used as a last resort when the
company was really losing money right
did not exist that's number one number
two the whole idea of rank and yank that
Jack Welch popularized where you rank
the entire company based solely on
performance you promote the top 10 and
fire at the bottom 10 every single year
with no assessment as to are they
stabbing each other on the others High
performers bad for the culture stabbing
each other in the back for their
individual performance and of the low
performance struggling with other kinds
of issues maybe they're under stress
maybe it's market conditions who knows
didn't matter you get ranked you get
fired you get promoted guess what that
did to the culture everybody was
stabbing each other right
um
the
um the imbalance of shareholder
Supremacy
taking care of our shareholders was
always a thing that's not an issue but
it wasn't considered more important than
the customer or the employee we now live
in a world where the shareholder is now
considered more important than the
customer and the employee employee and
you hear bankers and CEOs talk they're
talking nonsense when they talk about
their fiduciary duty right it's
completely made up
um and that all was popularized by Jack
Welch he was the poster child for all of
these new ways of running business that
are now completely standardized one of
my favorite stories is actually from
Gary Ridge is the CEO he just retired
CEO of WD-40 which is a public company
and he was on his analyst call and his
analyst said Gary you missed your
numbers and Gary said
um no I missed your numbers my numbers
are just fine